es el hombre récord de la NBA a lo largo
de 20 temporadas Lebron James se ha
hecho con los registros de anotación más
importantes de la liga superar la marca
histórica de puntos de Karim abdullabar
pone a James en la élite de la élite
James se sitúa también por encima de
Karmaland Kobe Bryant y el mismísimo
Michael Jordan algo que el mismo LeBron
creía imposible
creo que es uno de los récords más
grandes en el deporte en general es como
el récord de jonrones en béisbol
es como uno de esos récords que jamás
crees que serán superados la última vez
que sumó menos de 10 puntos en un
partido fue en enero de 2007 el mundo
por Entonces todavía escuchaba música en
iPod y desconocía la revolución del
iPhone un senador de Illinois llamado
Barack Obama preparaba aún su campaña
para las primarias demócratas por la
Casa Blanca Lebron James ha sido el
jugador más joven en llegar a los 5.000
10.000 15.000
25.000 y 30.000 puntos no he llegado a
este punto en mi carrera pensando en los
récords o en Cuántos puntos tengo
cualquiera que sea el caso simplemente
juego este deporte de la manera correcta
número uno del Draft en junio de 2003
comenzó su camino profesional con los
Cleveland cavaliers de su natal Ohio
después de siete temporadas pasó a Miami
en donde ganó sus primeros dos anillos
de la mano de un bixby de ensueño junto
con dway y Chris Bosch el buen hijo
volvió a casa en 2014 para cumplir su
promesa de levantar el título con los
cavaliers James lideró a Cleveland junto
con Irving hace su primer campeonato en
toda la historia una hazaña los caps se
convirtieron en el primer equipo que
remontaba un 3-1 adverso en unas finales
Y ante los temibles golden State
warriors fichó por los Ángeles Lakers en
2018 dos años más tarde levantó su
cuarto campeonato culminando un proyecto
de personal de resucitar una franquicia
grande en horas la edad no parece pasar
por el trono de Lebron rozando los 40
años en sus últimas dos temporadas tiene
un promedio de 30 puntos un registro
mejor que otras 16 campañas el rey James
aún no tiene fecha de abdicación porque
LeBron es LeBron con el 23 o con el 6